good morning this is sky news breakfast
thank you for joining us
health officials trying to stop new
coronavirus variants say there's been a
big increase in the number of people
coming forward for the vaccine
nhs england is reporting a sharp rise in
young adults getting the jab while
vaccine uptake amongst a range of ethnic
and religious groups
is also rising but infection rates are
still increasing
with official data showing cases in
england have gone up by around
three quarters in a week shingi maurike
reports
almost 40 million people have made the
trip to places like this vaccination
center in twickenham
that number includes many who have
overcome fears doubts and misinformation
for their dose of protection against
covert 19.
a couple of them hear some stuff
like things will happen to their body
and all that and
like i just trust the scientists and
just say that
i'm happy either way i spoke to family
members who had it they said it's all
right they're fine
so i decided to get it myself
a new survey for nhs england shows
growing numbers of people
are also overcoming vaccine hesitancy
an increase that includes ethnic
minority groups targeted in videos like
this one
we don't want you to die so please
hear us and when your turn comes
take the jab the data is encouraging
news for gps like fazana hussein who
spent the year trying to encourage
vaccine uptake in a local community
ravaged by covid
those are just amazing figures and you
think you know i don't mind
working after hours i don't mind working
in the evenings when we're seeing
results like that because these are live
saves there's nothing to describe that
feeling
the analysis produced by orb
international and the vaccine confidence
project has found 63 percent of people
aged 45 and under surveyed would
definitely get the jab
while a further 21 said they were likely
to accept it
this includes an 18 increase in under
45s from ethnic minority communities
it's not all good news though the indian
variant is taking hold in areas where
vaccine take-up is lower
including oldham where less than half of
the adult population have had their
second dose
working with the section of the
population who will be the last to
receive immunity has left this teacher
from the area worried
i think there's a there's an increase in
anxiety for everyone now as we recognize
the fact that
yes whilst we have got an increase in
vaccines across the country
young people are catching kovitz still
and our passing covered on
and while schools and local authorities
and parents are doing everything they
can to support
the management of this it undoubtedly
gives us more challenges in the school
day
even if people are more eager than ever
to get protected
in many ways it still feels like we've
got a long way to go
until we can leave this pandemic behind
shingi mararike
sky news well let's get the latest now
on the coronavirus data for the uk
there have been 6238 new coronavirus
cases
the highest total for more than two
months there were 11 deaths reported
which means the total number of people
who've died within 28 days of a positive
test
now stands at 127 823
meanwhile another 191 266 people have
received their first vaccination
and 377 641
have received their second that means
that 39.94 million people in the uk
have now received a first dose of a
coronavirus vaccine
thousands of pubs could be lost forever
that's the warning from
hospitality leaders this morning as the
call on the government to end the
lockdown by
june the 21st reports suggest that the
final stage of england's roadmap to ease
restrictions
could be delayed well as you can see uh
harriet hadfield joins me now from our
newsroom
harriet worrying news for pubs for sure
yes it is worrying isn't it and this is
uh figures that have been released um
looking at that week after may the 17th
so of course that was when people were
allowed to be
inside pubs and they found that when
they compare that exact week
uh with the same one in 2019 they only
took about 80 percent
of the of what happened two years ago so
that shows
a huge loss and there's also a lot of
concern that
people were really keen to get back into
pubs on may 17th but that
excitement might wane and so those
profits might be down even more so
they're really urging the government
please
don't put this great freedom day back
any longer because they might not be
able to sustain it at all
and various reports around this morning
harriet that
uh june the 21st might be pushed by at
least
two weeks yes so lots of different
reports in different
newspapers but one thing that a few of
them are reporting is this idea that the
government is considering
a two-week delay to to this great easing
that we're expecting
uh in in july so um that is something
that they are apparently
uh looking at you might say well two
weeks what's the point of that but
apparently it is all about the vaccines
uh and giving the 40 year olds under 40
year olds
a chance to have their second jab and so
that may
take it into july i should have said um
for the pubs though
two weeks is a long time and for the
hospitality sector
in general it's the fifth biggest sector
in the uk for business and they are
saying really we need to be
opening up we really can't take this
much longer
harriet thank you let's return now to
our top story the
rising number of people overcoming
vaccine hesitancy in coming forward for
their covet 19 injection
nhs england says there's been an
increase in the number of young adults
as well as ethnic and religious groups
willing to get the jab
joining me now is dr anil mehta a gp at
the full will cross medical center in
north london good morning to you um tell
us what you've been seeing in terms of
people
prepared to to actually take the
vaccination now good morning julian
thank you very much for giving me the
time it's been
an amazing effort so far i think what
we're seeing now is the as we go down
the groups
uh we are seeing younger people um
respond to the invitations that they've
been given by their practices by their
pharmacists and
the mass vaccination centers so i think
it's very very encouraging that we've
had a good uptake from the lower
uh the younger age groups and i think
we've got a bit of a way to go yet so
let's keep going what are you putting
the
increase in people being willing to take
the vaccination
down to is it purely the the campaigns
or is it
as time has has gone on people have
naturally come to the realization this
is the best way to protect themselves
and others i think julian is a mixture
of both really i think the consistent
message that actually the vaccines are
working we see the graphs that your
uh reports show us every night that
actually the the the uptake
increases because people start to have
the confidence that
vaccination really is the way forward i
think persuasion convincing
conversations with pharmacists doctors
healthcare workers
i think that all all has an effect on
people's uh
understanding and sometimes it's just a
bit of time that people need
uh to to to believe the science and and
and
that's it really we need we need more
conversations we need more campaigns
and from what we're we're seeing
according to nhs england um
a lot of younger people being persuaded
absolutely i think we see we've been
vaccinating in our practice in redbridge
in northeast london for many many months
i think we've seen a change in attitude
we've seen
younger people respond to their
invitations uh
respond to the messages that we send out
consistently we remind them that this is
the only way forward this is the way
that we
unlock ourselves and and that june 21st
deadline
uh becomes a reality if we keep sending
the same messages out julian that's very
very important and can't stress it
enough
what what have been the the reservations
in your experience
in the past what what really has been
holding people back up until now
so i think up until now there's been a
hesitancy because this is a new vaccine
this is a new
problem that the world faced i mean i
think there's there's naturally
apprehension
in in people about new medications new
treatments
so i understand that completely but i
think that as the evidence builds as we
get to know more and more about
vaccination
it changes people's minds and i think
it's a matter of time we
we social media unfortunately has scare
stories etc but
often when you talk to the right people
the right people in the medical world
it makes a difference yeah i mean there
are a lot of misconceptions
flying around out there one that i've
heard is that
many adults are saying that they're
willing to take what they consider to be
a risk
and sort of bank on the vaccine but not
so keen for
the younger members of their family you
know there might be issues some have
said with
fertility with younger women are you
able to dispel that that particular myth
i think the the evidence suggests that
actually there is no issues with
fertility with
anything more serious than an achy armor
headache temperature or fever
post-vaccination so i don't see we we
don't have any evidence of any long-term
effects off the vaccination
at the moment now i think with any
medicine it's a it's a challenge isn't
it because we try and convince people
it's
like anything if we prescribe blood
pressure medication or we prescribe
medication for diabetes we're we're on
the path of convincing people that
actually
this is the right treatment for your
condition so i don't i think we've got
to dispel the myths we've got to make
sure that people understand and put the
evidence in front of them to say
actually now you can make an informed
decision about what the best course of
action for you is and i think it's a
very individual decision at times
i think though that when you say that
there aren't any um
there's no evidence to to prove that
their long-term side effects at the
moment it's the
at the moment that worries people
i i don't i don't disagree julian i
think the medical world has
has proven over the years over over
decades that actually
medical treatment is often not without
issues however
we've seen the evidence that if you get
vaccinated with double dose
of the current vaccines that we have we
have prevented a lot of ill effects we
have prevented a lot of people hitting
those
hospital beds we've prevented deaths and
we've seen the figures come down
dramatically over the past few weeks and
months
so your message to those still perhaps
sitting on the fence would be
i'd urge you to take up the invitation
respond to the messages that your
practices that your pharmacists
offer you uh we've had a massive
campaign from all parts of our health
care system look at our number of
pharmacists that are offering the
vaccine now
our gp practices the hospital hubs the
mass vaccination centers i think
it's a concerted effort from all parts
of our health care system please take up
the offer of the invitation
respond if you have doubts talk to your
practice teams nurses and doctors
and dispel the myths that actually
there's anything more untoward than
an achy arm a headache or temperature or
feeling a bit groggy for a couple of
days
dr annel messer thank you very much for
speaking to us this morning sharing your
expertise with us thank you thank you
julian thank you
now airlines are putting on extra
flights and sending larger planes as
british holidaymakers try to get home
from portugal
they want to return after a change in
quarantine restrictions which will come
into
force uh in the early hours of tuesday
morning from about 4 am
let's speak now to abdur spokesperson
emma brennan
good morning to you um tell us first of
all
what the the situation is regarding um
people who might have holidays booked
that
are on the amber amber list what what
sort of um
rights do they have regarding those
holidays and perhaps cancellations and
and refunds you can still travel
to destinations that are on the amber
list
i think what would prevent you from
traveling to some of those destinations
would be
if the foreign office itself advised
against all that's essential travel
in those situations if you've got a
package holiday booked then you would be
entitled
to a refund or to be offered an
alternative
holiday or to ebook for a later date and
but if the foreign office isn't advising
against travel then you aren't
automatically entitled to a refund
however lots of travel companies are
being
flexible there's more flexibility around
holiday booking conditions than there's
ever been before
so you should check with your travel
company because even if they can't offer
you a refund they may be able to rebook
and provide or provide an alternative
holiday perhaps for later in the year or
for next year instead
so you don't have an absolute right to a
refund
it's very much um up to the the the
travel agent as to whether they
provide you with that yeah there isn't
any
um right under any of the regulations
that are from going from a green
list country to an ambulance country
that you would be entitled to a refund
unless the foreign office advises
against all but essential travels so for
the likes of
portugal it isn't doing that at the
moment
a lot of people will be able to travel
to
the places like portugal and places on
the ambulance and be able to quarantine
on return so we expect that some people
will still
go ahead with their holidays as planned
but we know that that will be a
challenge that the
the quarantine requirements will be
difficult for some people
and if if that applies to you then to
speak to your travel company to
find out what your options are but i
would also say if you're not traveling
until after the end of june that to just
sit tight
and wait and see which i know sounds
easier
than actually you know in practice it
can feel a bit uncomfortable not knowing
what's happening
but the reason i say that is the
government does have another review are
planned at the end of june and that will
be looking at two things
one the country's on the traffic light
list so the countries that fall into
the green and the amber and the red list
and and hope has always been that as we
get closer to summer
more countries will move on to that
green list which is the easier way to
travel
and the second review that it's doing is
actually looking at the requirements to
travel
and the travel industry has said for a
very long time when you've got
um people who've been vaccinated do they
really need to be able to have to go
through the testing requirements and
other requirements
and that are in place at the moment so
these are the types of things that we're
encouraging the government to look at
and so at the end of june things may
change in time for holidays in july
august and september onwards yeah
providing a bit of hope there although
it is still
quite precarious because uh the watch
list
for countries um on the the greenness
that the government promised to to warn
travel agents and those in the industry
before making any decision
they didn't add her to this time round
with with portugal so that there could
still be very last minute decisions i
you might travel to a country that's on
the greenness and as we see with
portugal
whilst you're out there that the status
changes
i think sadly this still is going to be
a degree of some
uncertainty even if we do get those
changes at the end of june which is why
it's really important
when you're planning and booking uh your
holidays that you're very clear
at what the uh the the um terms and
conditions are you know what what are
your rights
uh if uh something does change in what
situation do you leave that continue
will you be left in
and travel companies really are trying
to do um
their best to be as transparent and as
clear as possible and guide people
through this process not just booking
but i know they've been
uh going above and beyond over the last
few weeks to make sure that
people uh know everything they need to
know their sources when it comes to
meeting the requirements to travel at
the moment we want people
to be able to get on away on holiday we
know they've been desperate
to get away not just on holiday but also
to visit family and friends so
the industry is trying to support people
as much as possible
emma you hoping to get away have you got
anything booked yeah so i've got
a trip that's booked in france for um
july and so fingers crossed that we'll
still be able to get out there and
you know we've also been looking at some
more trips uh later on in the year as
well so
hoping to get my first family holiday
with my little boy
on overseas oh good luck hope hope you
make it out there
thanks very much for speaking to us this
morning thank you
also making the news this morning the
world's leading economies appear to be
on the brink of a deal to tax
tech firms like amazon apple google and
facebook
finance ministers of the g7 nations are
meeting in london to stop businesses
moving profits to countries with lower
tax rates france has said it will allow
british travelers who've had both doses
of a covered vaccine to enter the
country
from wednesday travers will still need
to quarantine for 10 days on their
return
home with france currently on the amber
travel list
vladimir putin has accused the u.s of
trying to withhold russia's development
with sanctions against the kremlin
at the same time the russian president
said there were no disagreements with
the u.s
ahead of a summit with president biden
he also denied russia had any role
in the false landing of orion air flight
and the detention of journalist roman
prozoc
in belarus
it's better not to interfere in belarus
affairs it's better to give people time
to sort it out without a rush
all in all even if they say that some
regimes suppress something
all in all changes in any society will
happen according to objective
circumstances
related to the development of the
society
around 500 people on the island of sotra
on norway's west
coast have been allowed to return home
after a major fire
the blaze is said to have been contained
but officials have warned it could take
days to
completely extinguish it
events begin in coventry today to mark
the beginning of its year as the uk city
of culture the coventry moves event
is being streamed online for people at
home
due to coronavirus restrictions
and one very lucky person in britain is
a lot richer
this morning a single uk ticket holder
won the euromillions jackpot of 111
million pounds last night after matching
seven numbers in the draw
unsurprisingly organisers last night
suggested players in britain might want
to
check their tickets
well it's not me and it's not joe
because she's here to do the weather
you would tell us wouldn't you he
wouldn't be here
that was the first i knew of it i was
thinking
i think you've got to buy a ticket first
to be honest anyway in terms of
the weather it's a bit of a lottery over
the next few days um
we've got a bit of a mixed bag to pick
from but temperatures stay on the warm
side it's not looking too bad
so let's look at today's detail
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well we
know the sun is shining on one person in
the uk today we just don't know who it
is
uh for the rest of us we're looking
really to inland areas out towards the
east we've still got a lot of gloom from
where we had that rain
over southeastern parts yesterday and
out towards the west there's a weak
frontal system which has
managed to creep its way in across parts
of ireland western parts of scotland
and it'll give some showery outbreaks
there so really it is these central
areas that see the best of the weather
certainly to start the day
so temperatures up to around 24 25
degrees celsius
about 75 degrees fahrenheit later on
though we start to see this cloud
and rain making its way into parts of
devon cornwall parts of wales
it's heading towards the midlands and up
towards the northeast it'll probably
skip north wales and parts of northern
england
and as we go into this evening and
overnight we'll find that parts of
ireland
and scotland actually see the better
weather and that's going to continue
into sunday as well
so fairly mild overnight for parts of
england and wales a little bit cooler
over parts of scotland and northern
ireland that's where you'll find the
sunshine tomorrow rather gloomy without
breaks of rain elsewhere
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
after the killing of george floyd by a
police officer in the united states
the chief constable of the west midlands
pledged to recruit a thousand
new police officers from ethnic minority
backgrounds
a year on there's been success with
recruitment of south asian officers
but the force is still struggling to
increase the number of black officers
shaman freeman powell reports from
birmingham
i'm coming for you come on this isn't
banter
between mates it's a sign of a police
force accepting it has issues
engaging with the community it serves
and trying to do more
that's live that's good a year ago these
officers watched the video
showing the final moments of george
floyd's life
it kind of feels like your candle is
being burnt on both ends so you feel the
pain from the black community and as a
black man seeing
someone you could recognize as a friend
cousin brother or even yourself
but then you also have the professional
disappointment of i know how it's
supposed to be done
and seeing it go so horribly wrong i
mean both sides of
both sides of your very person are
screaming almost at odds with each other
no one understands those dueling
loyalties more than the forces most
senior female officer the uniform
represents something to our community
but karen geddes believes george floyd's
death has sparked real change
but what i've seen in police training is
a conversation with staff around how we
go into incidents how we understand
historical context
so if one thing george fluid has had an
impact on wooden policing
it's definitely changing how we train
and upskill our staff around cultural
competence
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait he
didn't do anything in the last 12 months
high-profile stop and search videos have
gone viral
leading to questions about police
tactics
it's an interesting experience being
stopped by the police
my name is nathaniel james i'm a star
person nathaniel has been stopped and
searched over 300 times
he now runs a workshop helping young
people understand the law
and their rights there's been other
situations here
where like police officers put me in
handcuffs here never asked me a question
if you're black you're almost nine times
more likely to be stopped and searched
by the police
so how many of you guys have been
stopped and searched by the police
at this workshop it's clear that
negative experiences
have detrimental impacts on the
relationship between both communities
there's a lot of distrust they're
paranoid they don't know their rights
they feel like some of them feel like
they've been extorted in in
in a sense one solution could be to
recruit more black officers
about 17 of our recruits now from uh
black and ethnic military communities
i think that is a good start but the
population is 35
and probably higher the numbers of black
officers playing is awfully poor
um so we one percent of our officers are
black about one percent of our recruits
are we're not going to change the force
and so we you know kind of just coming
up to a year into that recruitment
process
we're doing a lot of work looking at
what more we can do but even with a more
representative force there's still the
problem of reversing
years of mistrust would you ever
consider a career in the police boss
not personally now i think um
[Music]
there's a lot of work that needs to be
done in the police force there's a lot
of things that need to be changed
i think there needs to be uh it needs to
be changed from the top down
you mean no no no it's just not really
my thing to be honest that you know it's
not it's not really my
yeah i mean no i wouldn't see you my
friend a community which feels
over-policed and under-protected
and a force trying hard to change
no worries at all you stay safe shaman
freeman powell
sky news birmingham
16 months of lockdown restrictions have
radically affected our personal finances
figures from the bank of england
suggests we've managed to save up nearly
170
billion pounds which is now sitting in
bank accounts let's get more on this
story from personal
finance journalist anne ashworth morning
to you
this might shock you but i haven't saved
up a hundred and seventy two million
pounds
um what what is the average amount that
people have saved
during the pandemic well it depends on
their circumstances but
the british have been putting up aside
almost twice
the amount they normally do in you know
about
10 to 15 billion every month as
and it used to be about half that and
the question mark is now
have we really got the savings habit big
time permanently or
are we going to go out and spend all of
this money
well i mean the bank of england has
previously said that they would actually
like us to
to to go out and spend you know when we
can
100 to boost the the economy
are people likely to do that or do you
think they've got used to having
lump sums saved up
i think some people will be willing to
spend on their houses
we're not perhaps going to be going
abroad maybe making their gardens more
lovely for a bit of staycationing in the
backyard but there is some sense that
people are beginning to pay off
credit card and other debts which is a
very wise thing
to do i suspect some people will put the
money towards their mortgage which
again would be a wise thing to do but i
think there are and
this is indeed what the bank of england
and the government is hoping that
pen those pent up savings will be
unleashed and we will go out and
buy some new clothes go to restaurants
and generally have ourselves a really
good time
yeah and so much has changed you know
people talking now about
um hybrid ways of working not
being a wholesale return perhaps to the
office so people thinking about
creating more space so that they can
have offices
at home i mean that will take
considerable funds to to
refurbish homes i think people will be
making themselves chic little work units
but
the one of the
most interesting things about working
from home is it's made us more
interested in our investments
so people have been opening accounts at
these investment platforms these online
financial supermarkets looking up where
some savings they had what see what's
happening to them
and making new savings and a lot of
those new customers
of those financial platforms a younger
people who are thinking
maybe they need to build financial
security for the future because
the pandemic has changed us and how we
feel
about our money in a great much else in
life back with us now to take us through
the newspapers this morning broadcaster
affio dom
and editor of challenges northern
ireland thomas
copeland welcome back to you both uh
we're going to start with the the
telegraph um and um the fact that we
might not be alone atheists
slightly scary photo i think that
they've mocked up on the
this uh story i think so anyway i think
it's scary
yeah i agree it is a bit of a worrying
picture so this is a story
in the telegraph um that the us have
been doing an investigation
into ufos there's an intelligence report
that's going to be put before the senate
on the 25th of june
and this report has found that although
it has no evidence
of ufos it cannot rule them out
completely
so um it examined 120 ufo sightings over
the last
12 decades and eliminated the
possibility that the in
the the car because of secret black op
us intelligence programs if you will
and it put those sightings down to
probably hypersonic
chinese and russian uh aircraft or
germans that they have
invented and so there actually is a
worry in washington that perhaps beijing
and moscow have technological advances
that united states
simply don't have and have managed to
create this hypersonic
super-fast vehicles you know ahead of
the united states
but the report said it also couldn't
rule out things like
uh the unusual direction in which these
aircrafts
could move uh moving frequently side to
side
and really rapid acceleration or going
in and out of water
it couldn't explain how those aircraft
could do that so therefore it cannot
rule out that there could be ufos
but it hasn't found any evidence that
there are ufos
so this is a little less x-files and
more a case of the us being concerned
about their national con national
security excuse me
and also being concerned that china and
russia have developed
hypersonic technology that they don't
have their hands on as yet
yeah no no proof but they can't rule it
out i mean i refer to
the photos being scary um others might
think it's it's really exciting
thomas which camp are you in
i don't know probably scary i think the
aliens just through a
pandemic they think you give us a couple
of months before they invade sure i mean
we want to get back to the pub for a bit
before the next major global crisis
occurs
let's move on then shall we to the ft um
you've had a look at this story the g7
finance minister
meeting what's happening there yeah much
more somber story
i'm afraid it looks like one of the
major results of the g7 taking place
currently
in cornwall will be in relation to the
taxation of multi-national corporations
profits by the end of the day we're
probably expecting a communique from the
major western
democracies or their finance ministers
to black to back a global
minimum rate of 15 for multinational
corporations
in particular you know in your mind
think about the big tech companies
things like google facebook microsoft
these are the kind of companies that the
us under joe biden has been quite
concerned about
um largely due to uh sort of
international
uh tax systems whereby uh you know
you are paying tax on your hq or where
your patents are or where your
trademarks are
rather than where most of your sales are
taking place so this is a measure
designed to alleviate some of those
problems
there's a bunch of ins and outs still to
be sorted out but
when this communique is published
probably at the end of the day this is
going to be a major development in the
way that international taxation works
at two things i'll say quickly in terms
of maybe domestically where it is um
it's most important one does this
represent a change in the way the
conservative party has looked at
corporation tax in particular
um i'm thinking back to under cameron
for example and osborne
lowering corporation taxes always
something to which they aspired
it was associated in their minds anyway
with an increase in jobs and prosperity
um rishi has already increased the uk
tax
uh corporation tax rate for example from
1900
it's going up to 25 um or does this
actually say that
this is about boris johnson maybe trying
to cozy up a bit to joe biden there's
very little to lose if the um
if the uk corporation tax rate is rising
anyway
um the other way of looking at this i
suppose particularly
uh from the eu perspective is that the
eu is represented here by pascal donahue
who's the irish finance minister
um ireland has always had or sorry has
had for the last number of years
a very low corporation tax rate about
12.5 percent and a great number of big
u.s and particular tax firms have based
their headquarters there
and that twelve point five percent rate
has been uh backed and defended by
successive
fina gilfin of all uh governments over a
number of years as bringing jobs
investments
um and prosperity to ireland
its critics say that you know it's all
souffle there's nothing really
underneath it it's all about these
companies
not paying much tax not actually
delivering that much in jobs
so actually the major opposition here
could become could come from
the eu in particular countries like
ireland rather than the tories we seem
to be quite happy
to back joe biden on this but um by the
end of the day we'll see
where the battle lines are drawn yeah i
know interesting it
could be groundbreaking as you say to
the times affair
and uh the the headline there the uh
boast of
boris johnson and the uk government that
half of adults
uh have been vaccinated fully vaccinated
but the
but is that depending on where you live
according to the times
a huge caveat there jillian a real butt
and so
yes boris johnson has been typing that
over half
of adults have been vaccinated but that
really does vary depending on
where you live so in toward for instance
um around 23 and a half percent of
adults have been vaccinated
that's the worst performing area tower
hamlets in london
um but in the isle of wight it's 64
around 67
excuse me have been vaccinated there so
it seems that in big cities and such as
london manchester and newcastle they
have the lowest rate
of adults being vaccinated now some
people are saying
that um people tend to be more transient
in big cities perhaps
they move there or they move more often
they may not be registered with the gp
or maybe registers at their old address
and perhaps have missed an appointment
letter to come and get the vaccination
but of course we do still have some
vaccine hesitancy
and that is amongst um some of these
areas especially in london
or particularly in london and they have
low uh
uptake of the vaccine power hamlets
being one of them
we've been running today that uh there's
evidence that people more people are
taking up the the vaccine and that the
levels of hesitancy have been
quite drastically reduced oh absolutely
and yes the levels of hesitancy are
going down but they still have
some way to catch up and it's really
important that those areas that have low
vaccine uptake
and can be more encouraged to take up
vaccine
because those areas tend to be more
affected by covert 19.
now this report also says that across
the country
94 of uh the over 65 the older age group
have had both of their nine the both of
their vaccinations
and they actually make up 90 of all
deaths so that's great that
that age group are certainly on the
button and on the uptake with the
vaccinations
but it also shows that the facts seem
roll out there is still some work to do
across the country if you want to get
those rates up if you want to encourage
people to come
back for their second vaccination or
this talk of bringing down
the wait time from 12 weeks to eight
weeks so it just shows that we need to
keep
encouraging people to come for their
vaccination for the first those
and of course that all-important second
dose as well so we can get those rates
all across it is an ongoing campaign um
thomas
tell us what gordon brown is warning
boris johnson
about this is in the guardian this is a
features on the front page of the
guardian and it's an interesting
exclusive interview that they featured
in in the paper today as well so i mean
gordon brown's post
dining street career has looked rather
more positive than some of his fellow
former
prime ministers in recent times he's
releasing a book seven ways to change
the world it's called it's all about a
passion of his which is uh globally
multi-global multi-nat
excuse me globally global
multilateralism just about that one
night
do you think it's out of time but
basically he's saying that his mistakes
will catch up with him